foreign
hi Kennedy how are you
hi Dave how are you better than we
deserve what's up
hey so I was calling because
um I had a son he's four and a half and
his dad and I are no long together but
I'm in a great marriage now and we are
actually on baby step two we're working
steps and uh my son's dad he's not very
good with money you know we built the
house together I wasn't on it obviously
but we built a house together and he
picked out everything that was super
expensive he went and he bought a brand
new Jeep when he had kind of a beater he
lived to like impress people and he's
not a bad dad we're on good terms but
he's just really bad with money and I'm
trying to work with my son now on chores
and saving money and making money and
I'm I'm worried that his dad is going to
show him habits like going out to eat
all the time and buying every single
thing and it's just kind of going to
reverse what I do here at home can you
help with that
yeah I mean this is this can be a tough
one the good news is though Kennedy I
mean your son's five which is great
right I mean they're young and yes
impressionable but but you can start
doing things with him
um that's not going to completely
unravel just because he sees his dad and
I think
parents and I have to even realize this
even with my kids so much of what they
learn is what they're watching and so
more is caught than taught and you only
have the power to control what goes on
in your house you don't have the power
to control what's going to be going on
in your husband's house and so I think
the older he gets the more conversations
you guys can have around money but right
now where you're at the fact that he's
five I think instilling these small
habits and again Kennedy I we have a
five-year-old at home we do this stuff I
teach it every day and we still probably
aren't as intentional as we should be
with our kids right so like there's a
lot of Grace in this it's okay
um they're still young but I think you
know slowly but surely that consistency
over time of what he's going to see from
you that's what you can control and so
that's what I would focus my energy on
um and again I'm sure as he gets older
there's gonna be more questions and I
think you have those conversations with
respect for his dad and still honoring
him but also telling the truth of hey
here's what common sense looks like when
it comes to money here's how to hear our
habits to have to set you up to win
right because I think it was Meg Meeker
that said we don't raise kids just to be
good kids we raise them to be good
adults and so yes I love Meg Meeker yeah
it's kind of having that long-term
mindset uh is helpful too but um you
know Meg would tell you first and
foremost never trashes dad to him
absolutely circumstances are ever going
to happen but then sometimes the way I
can find my answer on some of these
things is if I take it to an extreme it
tells me how to handle it let's take it
let's take a different thing instead of
money let's just make up something kind
of weird or wild to see how we would
handle that let's say his dad drops the
F-bomb every other word he does actually
that's right who knew and um and we
don't do that at our house okay we don't
okay so how do we handle that well we
don't trash dad
and we can't control what Dad does with
his mouth over at the other place but we
can only control it when you're with me
and in this house we don't speak that
way
we have more class than that
we're not trash
okay uh you know we have we have a sense
of decorum we have a sense of nobility
in our home and we don't we don't speak
using those types of words uh they're
called vulgar we don't teach a
four-year-old that but I mean this is
what's going through your mind right and
so you go what I can't catch all that
but all I can control is what we do here
and and so your interaction with him is
we don't do that when you're here
okay and uh you know we don't do that
here and so we don't when we're here we
work and we do our chores when we're
here we're generous with our money when
we're here we save our money when we're
here we make wise purchase decisions
with our money as coached by our mom I
and then that's all you can do now what
will happen at the end of the story is
this okay common sense and love and
proper truth does win out in these
things but it takes time so when he's 26
and he did something stupid with money
he's going to know what stupid looks
like because it was described to him by
you
and so he's going to go gosh I really
can't model my life after my dad my
mom's plot process works I need to
gravitate back to that and I'm going to
probably go to my mom yeah and if I need
it if I need help if I need financial
advice I don't go to my dad who's broke
I'm gonna go to my mom who taught me
this stuff the whole time growing up and
but that he'll go through the phase like
all kids do we're first you're you you
know somewhere around 14 years old my
mama is stupid gland kicks in right and
then it takes until about 30 or 25 or
whatever for it to grow back right
before and then suddenly at some point
in their 20s or whatever you're a genius
again and you're going to go through
that regardless of whether you're
together or whether you're apart so uh
uh you know that's gonna happen here
it's not going to be a perfect path and
there's not anything you can do to
protect him from
uh bad money habits or vulgar mouths
when they exist with your ex because the
truth is too can
you can have been in a marriage raising
him and doing everything possible to
teach them new wives with money and then
at the end of the day when they go off
on their own suddenly they're adults
that have to make their own decisions
too and you know right we're getting
even that second generation of Ramsay so
like that that kids that grew up
listening to Dave on the show make very
sure you talk about what you and your
current husband are doing to the
four-year-old in age-appropriate ways so
they see the model
and you coach him on his personal
Behavior so he sees the model and then
it'll work out it's going to be okay but
there's no Ironclad protection when
you've got
you know when he's going to get exposed
to the virus on the other side
so okay you know it's just like the
mouth thing it's the same thing and so
you're get you just got a bad model over
there and that that's that's you know
and but you can't fix your ex-husband
that's why he's your ex
so and you can't control him that's why
you're he's your ex but even with
parents too what I was saying earlier
was you know even if you do
and about any any area of parenting
right you oh there's no guarantee yeah
right so all you can do is give it your
best shot that's right so that's what I
would say too Kennedy is like give
yourself some Grace yeah do what you can
in your household and then at the end of
the day launching them into the world
it's like okay if you model it Morse
caught then taught and you teach it
you've done all you can do that's your
best shot and it works out more times
than not
so that's why we do it that's why we do
it hang on we're going to send you a
copy of smart money smart kids that
Rachel and I did together teaching your
children how to be smart with money so
that when they grow up they have a brain
and what's hard in those situations is
like the Disney dad thing too when they
go to Dallas when they go to Mom or
Dad's house that's the spender and it's
like oh we're gonna have all this fun
into a kid it's like oh this is way more
fun and that's a hard pill to swallow
too when you're the parent like I think
I've only grown up in this equation I
know
you're doing great Kennedy